um
is there going to be uh
i just want to thank you because
you are uh obviously nas has a lot to do
with it but just in terms of kind of
i don't know what it is about your
relationship with nas but it has
inspired him to release a high quantity
of music
over the last couple of years
the fact we got magic just as like a
bonus last year was [ __ ] incredible i
think magic low-key might be my favorite
of the three albums that's the funny
thing and that's what's motivational for
me and i would say him as well is the
fact that every time we drop a project
people are like nah this one better than
the last one they've gotten better each
time exactly so my thing is like let's
just keep leveling it up every time and
kind of just competing with ourselves
we're not obviously nas is who he is
like he's he's cemented in this [ __ ] and
you know legend royalty all that but
it's like he just motivated to to make
the music and it's just strictly about
that and that's why it's just leveling
up how much of kings disease three is uh
has been worked on yeah i can't say a
percentage man but you guys it's it's
it's happening i mean you know he said
it don't imagine yeah i'm saying he said
it so it's on the white so it is on the
way it's on the way nice is it when you
guys get in for a new project is it is
there any sort of direction or is it
just such an organic vibe that it's like
whatever comes out comes out you guys
guys that's basically how it is like
because we we just kept recording after
kd2 and you know it was a moment where i
was like maybe this is kd3 and was like
nah we got to just go with a completely
new concept and he just was knocking him
out up until the point where it was like
nah we got to drop some you know two out
202 in one year that shit's big bro wow
and it's crazy too because like i know
you guys won
you got something to say
say what up
he's like i'm straight
i was gonna say uh you guys obviously
won uh grammy for rap album of the year
in 2021 right 2020. 2020. yeah [ __ ] the
whole last couple of years
everything is just oh man it's crazy
yeah but i feel like kings disease 2 was
the better album
of oh what exactly i mean that's how a
lot of people feel yeah i feel like
magic is better than the last the other
two exactly so it's like that's why you
can't really call it man like you got to
just
just keep it pushing after you know the
decision like even with my producer of
the year award i was going to say 20 20
you got you got snubbed 2021 it came
back around you got the nomination
that's the nomination you should have
took the award a lot of people have said
that but it is what it is you got to
keep pushing for that next year